[Musica]
e se vi chiedessi A quale tra le
seguenti fonti energetiche voi non
rinuncereste per la produzione di
energia di oggi e di domani vi chiedo di
rispondere a questa domanda sulla base
di tre parametri che sono le emissioni
di gas effetto serra il consumo di suolo
e il fattore di carico Ecco quest'ultimo
ci dice Quanta energia per quanto tempo
una fonte energetica può lavorare ora
100% significa che può rimanere sempre
accesa 0% significa sempre spenta Ecco
vi chiedo di rispondere alzando la mano
in platea e potete anche rispondere per
più di una fonte quindi chi non
rinuncerebbe alla fonte con le missioni
più alte
chi non rinuncerebbe alla fonte numero 2
con emissioni basse ma anche un fattore
di carico basso e quindi si dice una
fonte intermittente
vedo qualche mano e chi non rinuncerebbe
la fonte numero 3 che per tutti e tre i
fattori ha i numeri migliori
Ok Vedo delle mani Vedo delle mani
e bene Oggi sono qua a parlarvi di
energia nucleare e voi vi chiederete
perché è una ragazza di 28 anni è in
Italia a parlare di energia nucleare ma
non lo sa che ci sono stati referendum
abbiamo votato e noi di energia nucleare
in Italia non ne vogliamo parlare Ecco
so che ci sono stati referendum sto il
risultato del referendum Ma penso che
sia importante parlare di energia
nucleare in Italia e penso sia
importante farlo Indipendentemente dalle
scelte che sono state fatte e che
verranno fatte in Italia per quanto
riguarda la nostra produzione energetica
penso sia importante farlo perché nel
mondo già oggi l'energia nucleare
rappresenta una grossa fetta
dell'energia prodotta con basse
emissioni in questo grafico Vi mostro
come è stata prodotta nel 2021 l'energia
elettrica Ecco il 10% è prodotta da
fissione nucleare nel mondo ci sono 437
reattori nucleari in operazione ce ne
sono 56 in costruzione in Europa ancora
più energia prodotta eh per Fonte
nucleare circa il 30%
la seconda cosa che vorrei farvi notare
che abbiamo in Europa rispetto al mondo
Abbiamo un una minore dipendenza dai
combustibili fossili e questa è ottenuta
con l'aiuto e l'insieme di fonti
rinnovabili ed energia nucleare ora
quindi l'energia nucleare non ha
ostacolato in alcun modo lo sviluppo
delle fonti rinnovabili questa cosa la
vediamo bene anche in Italia dove non
abbiamo la fetta verde del energia
nucleare le rinnovabili sono molto
sviluppate Ma la fetta che era verde
chiaro nel grafico europeo qui è
rimpiazzata e sostituita da gas naturale
ora un'altra cosa che forse non tutti
sanno è che in Italia non produciamo
energia nucleare Ma la consumiamo quasi
il 10% dell'energia che consumiamo in
Italia arriva la fissione nucleare e
arriva dalla Francia dalla Slovenia e
dalla Svizzera noi semplicemente la
importiamo
Ma poi vi parlo di energia nucleare
Anche perché qualcosa che mi affascina e
mi appassiona da sempre infatti pensate
che quando ero alle medie e volevo fare
la fisioterapista e non l'ingegnere
nucleare Ecco allora ho portato in
tesina all'esame di terza media proprio
i reattori a fissione nucleare e l'ho
fatto se riesco a prenderlo perché la
cosa che più mi affascinava era Quanta
energia si può produrre con quanto poco
combustibile Ecco questo è la
riproduzione in scala 1 di un elementi
di un pellet di combustibile come quelli
che ci sono nei reattori nucleari Ecco
con questa quantità di combustibile
riusciamo a produrre tutte le energie
necessaria per soddisfare il fabbisogno
di una famiglia per un anno
ora per produrre la stessa quantità di
energia ci vorrebbero queste quantità
quindi una tonnellata di carbone oppure
400 più di 400 metri cubi di gas o più
di 400 litri di petrolio l'altra cosa
interessante che avendo così poco
combustibile anche il rifiuto è molto
poco quindi una volta che il
combustibile è usato Questa è quello che
ci rimane pensate che se voi utilizzaste
solo energia nucleare per tutta la
vostra vita per fare tutte le attività
della vostra vita alla fine di 80 anni
avreste prodotto un po' meno di una
lattina di bibita con dentro rifiuti ad
alta attività e voi Mi direte Ecco Ok va
bene sono pochi ma sono radioattivi Lo
sappiamo tutti che i rifiuti radioattivi
le scorie radioattive sono un problema
irrisolto dell'energia nucleare Ecco
vorrei provare a spiegarvi perché non è
così e vorrei farlo
raccontandovi qualcosa di quella cosa
che caratterizza e distingue i rifiuti
radioattivi dai rifiuti normali Ecco
questa cosa si chiama radioattività
la radioattività è qualcosa che esiste
in natura da sempre non l'ha inventata
l'uomo Infatti pensate nel terreno
nell'area nell'acqua ci sono elementi
radioattivi nei mattoni di questo
bellissimo Castello ci sono elementi
radioattivi nel nostro corpo ci sono
elementi radioattivi Pensate un uomo di
circa 70 kg è soggetto a 5.000
decadimenti radioattivi al secondo
quindi siamo tutti delle Sorgenti
radioattive e la seconda cosa molto
interessante della radioattività è che
può essere misurata con una facilità
estrema una parte su un milione di
miliardi Questa è una concentrazione
minuscola pensate la differenza di
dimensioni è un po' come il pellet di
prima con la distanza tra la Terra e il
Sole
Ok quindi la possiamo misurare molto
facilmente E allora vorrei provare a
sfatare due miti Il primo è che è
davvero molto difficile nascondere
materiale radioattivo o rifiuti
radioattivi è difficile nascondere
perché con strumenti che trovate su
internet per poche centinaia di Euro
potete misurare livelli di radioattività
molto molto bassi molto inferiore a
quelli pericolosi per l'uomo e la
seconda cosa è che quando sentiamo
magari leggiamo una notizia sentiamo il
telegiornale che ci sono stati misurati
dei livelli di radioattività anomali da
qualche parte bene chiediamoci anomali
di quanto perché
anomali per qualche parte su milioni di
miliardi sono anomali li possiamo
misurare ma di certo non sono pericolosi
per l'uomo e allora quando parliamo di
rifiuti radioattivi il punto non è sono
radioattivi Allora sono pericolosi il
punto è capire quando la radioattività
presente in queste in questi rifiuti io
in questi materiali e in quantità
sufficienti da essere pericoloso per
l'uomo e soprattutto
progettare inventare costruire soluzioni
tecnologiche che ci permettano di
fermare questa radioattività e di
rendere i rifiuti non pericolosi e
soluzioni tecnologiche di questo tipo
esistono ed esistono da decenni infatti
abbiamo capito molto bene come fare a
fermare tutti i tipi di radiazione
ionizzante abbiamo capito che diversi
materiali fermano meglio diversi tipi di
radiazioni abbiamo capito che spessori
ci vogliono per fermare certi tipi di
radiazioni a che energie e esempi li
abbiamo tutti è molto comuni quando
andiamo dal dentista e facciamo la
radiografia ai denti ci viene messo sul
petto una piccola pettorina di piombo
Ecco questa serve esattamente a fermare
le radiazioni X che ci stanno facendo la
radiografia al dente e non farla
arrivare al petto la stessa cosa le
pareti degli ospedali dei reparti di
medicina nucleare questi sono fatte
apposta perché chi è in sala d'attesa
non riceva alcun tipo di effetto dalla
radiazione presente nella sala di
trattamento Ecco esattamente la stessa
cosa si fa con i contenitori per i
rifiuti radioattivi e i depositi per i
rifiuti radioattivi che esistono in
tutto il mondo
E allora come facciamo a dire quando la
radioattività si è fermata quando
abbiamo costruito una barriera
sufficiente Ecco si utilizza una come
grandezza come guida una grandezza che
si chiama Dosa efficace la dose efficace
ci dice ci va a stimare quelli che sono
gli effetti della radiazione sull'uomo e
in questo grafico Vi mostro come
distribuita la dose efficace media di un
cittadino europeo in un anno Ecco più
dell'80% della dose non ha nulla a che
vedere quell'uomo e con le attività
umane Se l'uomo non avesse mai imparato
a utilizzare la radioattività o le
reazioni nucleari Ecco questo contributo
ci sarebbe comunque perché deriva da i
radionuclidi naturali deriva dalla
radiazione cosmica che arriva
dall'universo per quanto riguarda il
contributo antropico quindi quello
dovuto dal quello dovuto dall'uomo quasi
la totalità è dovuto a i trattamenti
medici di cui dicevamo prima quindi
radiografie piuttosto che trattamenti di
terapia
quelle che sono le applicazioni civili
del nucleare Ecco qui Inseriamo la
produzione di energia inseriamo il
trattamento dei rifiuti inseriamo anche
la radioattività che è stata emessa in
ambiente a causa degli incidenti
nucleari Ecco tutti questi contributi
pesano per meno dello
0,005% sulla nostra dose media annuale E
allora qui mi ricollego sicuramente
quella che sarà un po' tutti avrete
pensato Ok poche emissioni poche rifiuti
Ma se succede un incidente cosa facciamo
Siamo tutti morti Ecco anche per
rispondere a questa domanda e per
rispondere sul grado di sicurezza sul
grado di rischio associato a una
impianto nucleare proviamo a
confrontarlo con le altre fonti
energetiche e confrontiamolo utilizzando
come parametro il numero di decessi
causati da queste fonti per unità di
energia prodotta per calcolare il numero
dei decessi consideriamo sia gli
incidenti che anche il normale
funzionamento e quindi ad esempio
l'inquinamento che viene messo in
ambiente in atmosfera
Ecco questi sono i risultati ora la
prima cosa che vorrei farvi notare è che
nessuno è zero a nessuna Fonte
energetica come nessuna tecnologia è
associato un rischio zero ma la seconda
cosa che vorrei farvi notare che se noi
consideriamo sicure energie come le
eolico il solare idroelettrico Allora è
assolutamente lecito considerare sicuro
anche il nucleare
E allora vorrei concludere
Ritornando alla domanda dell'inizio e
vorrei farlo citando Un tema che non ho
ancora detto in modo esplicito il
cambiamento climatico è reale la
temperatura del nostro pianeta sta
aumentando il modo con cui noi
produciamo energia con cui ci spostiamo
con cui Costruiamo Ecco tutte queste
cose sono responsabili dell'aumento di
temperatura
il mondo però avrà sempre bisogno di
energia Allora noi dobbiamo reinventare
ripensare il modo con cui facciamo
sostanzialmente tutte queste attività e
dobbiamo farlo che abbiamo il dovere di
ridurre ed infine di azzerare le nostre
emissioni di CO2 e una soluzione facile
a questo problema non esiste ma
l'energia nucleare e le tecnologie
nucleari sono parte della soluzione e
allora il mio invito è quello di provare
a mettere da parte i pregiudizi e i
timori che abbiamo rispetto a questa
Fonte energetica queste tecnologie e
guardare ai dati e guardare a quello che
la ricerca scientifica ci dice perché
non possiamo permetterci di rinunciare a
nessuna delle fonti che abbiamo e delle
opzioni che abbiamo per risolvere questa
sfida che è enorme e che la nostra
generazione dovrà essere in grado di
affrontare Grazie
[Applauso]